ذلك ازمه انسانيه
وبالتالي
فان هذا ادى الى الماسه ماساه فيرار
المواطنين من منازلهم بسبب عمليته القصف
والجرائم المروعه التي ارتكبت
على ايدي الجنود الروس
ولكن شكرا جزيلا مره اخرى السيده الرئيس
على زيارتكم لان هذا دليل كبير على ان
العالم الحر لم ينسى هؤلاء المواطنين
السيد الرئيس ادرك مدى الشجاعه التي
يتطلبها الامر اتصور ان الامر لم يكن سهل
لاسيما بالنسبه لاولئك المسؤولين على
امنكم السيده الرئيس ارجو ان تنقل لهم
تقديري لجهودهم شكرا لك سيد الرئيس على
هذا القرار نحن سعداء ان نستضيفكم في
بولندا
وسوف نلتقي غدا مع حلفائنا في الجناح
الشرقي للنيت لان هذه الزياره رمزيه ومهمه
جدا بالنسبه لانها جميع نحن ننظر اليها
ليس كزيار الى بولندا وانما هي زياره الى
الاقليم والى كييف وهي تبعث برساله قويه
رساله مسؤوليه الولايات المتحده
تجاه امني اوروبا والعالم الولايات
المتحده التي اثبتت مرارا وتكرارا
مسؤوليتها تجاهها اوروبا كما حدث خلال
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وكذلك الحرب
البارده في كل مره
عملت الولايات المتحده على استعاده
الحكم القانون ونظام الديمقراطي واستطاعت
شعوب انت سعيده حريتها بعد عشرات السنين
كما حدث في بولنديه وذلك بفضل التضامن
وكذلك تصميم الشعب البولندي
وكذلك الضغط الذي مارسه الراحل البابا فول
الثاني ونحن نقدر هذا الموقف ونقدر موقف
رئيس ريجن ايضا
وفي النهايه فان
الامبراطوريه الشر انهارت وانهار ايزن
فيدار برلين
وانتصرنا معا
ونحن نعتقد بان امريكا قادره على الحفاظ
على النظام الدولي
وصونه وان تظهر لكل المعتدين الذين يريدون
تدمير حياه غيري هم وسيطر على بلدان اخرى
واستعبادها ايضا
الولايات المتحده تثبت بانه لا يمكن
للديمقراطيات ومثل المتحده ان تتقبل سلوكا
كهذا
شكرا لكم على ذلك كما قلت هذا دليل كبير
بالنسبه لنا نحن في اوكرانيا ولشعب
الاوكرانيا
هذه الزياره نحن السيد الرئيس سعداء بان
هناك رساله قويه تبعثون بها منهن للعالم
باسره والعالم كله سوف ينظر الى هذه
الزياره ونحن سعداء جدا بها وهذا يثبت
ايضا
مدى اهميه الاهميه بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده الوضع في اوروبا وكذلك بالنسبه
لنا هذا تاكيد باننا نقوم بالامر الصحيح
وما قمنا به مؤخرا من اجراءات في دعم
اوكرانيا من خلال ارسال الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا ومساعدتي الاوكرانيين ودعمهم
بسته السبل
هذا دليل بان هذا هو سبيل الصحيح وهذا
دليل باننا نحظى بدعم الولايات المتحده
نريد ان ندعم ايضا جيراننا ونحاول ان نقوم
بكل ما هو ضروري لتامين اوروبا ونحن لا
ننتظر فقط
الامنيه من الولايات المتحده وانما نقدم
هذه الضمانات الامنيه ايضا لجيراننا ودول
البلطيق وكذلك
لرومانيا حيث ينتشر جنود النيتو
في هناك ايضا جنود
بولنديون
وبكل بساطه نريد ان نظهر التضامن فيما بين
الحلفاء
والسيد الرئيس شكرا مره اخرى على القيام
بهذه الزياره الى بولندا نحن نرى او نحن
مقتنعون بان الشعب البولندي ينظر في هذه
الزياره دعم
لتحالفنا وقد حضينا بهذه الفرصه
لاستضافتكم هنا السيد الرئيس وهذا ايضا
يمثل اشاره قويه للمستثمرين في الغرب
السيد الرئيس هذا يثبت تناولندا بلد امن
ويمكن
للانسان ان يزوره من اي مكان كان على وجه
هذه المعموره بولندا بلد امن بفضل تواجد
القوات الامريكيه وكذلك قوات النيتو وبفضل
ايضا الجهود التي نبذلها لدعم امنه بولندا
وقدرتها الدفاعيه
ونحن سعداء السيد الرئيس لان زيارتكم دعم
قوي لهذا التواجد
الامريكي والغربي نحن نتواصل مع حلفاءنا
في اوروبا وقد
شاركت في اجتماع في لندن وخلال مؤتمر
ميونخ للامن واكدنا على هذه التطورات وهذا
الدور الوحيد الذي تقومون به السيد الرئيس
الدور الذي تقوم به الولايات المتحده الذي
يثبت ان الروابط بين ضفه الاطلس قويه
ومهمه
ورئيس الوزراء البولندي الذي هو رئيس
الحكومه لديه بين يديه مسؤوليه
الشؤون الحكومه وفي عام 2025 سوف تكون
بولندا او تتولى الرئاسه الدوريه للاتحاد
الاوروبي ونحن نرغب ان يتم تبني ق الاتحاد
الاوروبي بهذه المناسبه وان يتم التركيز
على تقويه العلاقات بين ضفه الاطلس بين
الولايات المتحده واوروبا وان يكون هناك
المزيد من التعاون بين الشركاء بين ضفتي
المحيط الاطلسي هذه المساله بالغه الاهميه
بنسبه لنا لان الاوقات التي نمر بها في
اوروبا حاليا بالغه الصعوب ودور الولايات
المتحده دليل صريح بان الشراكه مهمه لامن
اوروبا وتطورها المستقبلي نحن في بولندا
مررنا بالكثير من التجارب في القرن الماضي
لاسيما خلال 100 عام الماضي السيد الرئيس
مره اخرى نحن سعداء وهلا وسهلا بكم سيدي
شكرا جزيلا على الكرم الضيافه وحراره
الترحاب شكرا لكم على دعوه مجددا لزياره
وورسو في هذه الاوقات الحرجه ذكرت البابا
بولس واعتقد انك تتذكر القصه التي سردتها
عليك بشان عضو رفيع المستوى في مجلس الامن
القومي وكان هو اصغر الاعضاء سنا حيث كان
يبلغ اثنين وثلاثين عاما وكنت وعدت من
اوروبا
وكتبت تقرير قلت ان بولندا ستكون في غدوه
العامه فطلب مني اعضاء المجلس عدم قراءه
هذا الخطاب
تلقيت اتصالا من البابا وقد كانت لدي ارى
متحفظه جديدا
وبعد انهاء الاتصال هاتفي
وهو طبعا لم يشير الى مساله الكاثوليكيه
على الاطلاق خلال ذلك الاتصال الهاتف
بيننا
تحدثنا على امور
اثناء اللقاء الذي
كان بيننا
وقد قلت له اثناء الاستماع الذي جمعني به
لان هناك صوره
قال لي ايها السيناتور اليوم تحدثت اليك
كمواطن بولندي فخور بوطنه وليس بصفه الباب
اتذكر جيدا هذا الكلام الذي جمعنا
وقدرت بولندا العام الماضي
وقمت بزياره القاعده العسكريه التي بها
يتواجد الجنود الفولنديون والامريكيون
والحقيقه ان الولايات المتحده تحتاج
بولندا كما يحتاج بقدر ما تحتاج كولندا
للوطن المتحده وكذلك النيتو حتى نتمكن من
العمل في اي مكان في العالم ومسؤولياتنا
تتجاوز اوروبا الامن في اوروبا امر اساسي
وبسيطه
هذا التحالف قوي للغايه ربما هو التحالف
الاعظم في التاريخ المعاصر وفي التاريخ
بشكل عام اذا اوضحت بجلاه
ان التصريحات الولايات المتحده هي حقيقيه
تجاه الحلفاء
واكد ان النيت اقوى مما كان عليه على
الاطلاق وقلت لرئيس زيلينسكي عندما تحدثت
اليه في كييف بالامس انني استطيع ان اقول
بكل فقر ان دعمنا لاوكرانيا سوف لن يتزعزع
وكذلك اكدت على ذلك اليوم
وكما نرى ان هناك ايضا طبعا سعي لي دخول
اعضاء جدد الى النيتو
واعتقد نحن اذا
وصلنا النظر الى ما يجب التركيز عليه
سنكون في موضع موضع افضل من اي وقت مضى
واشكرك فخامه الرئيس على دعوكم لاوكرانيا
كان دعما استثنائي السيد الرئيس هذا حقيقه
عندما ياتي الاوكرانيون الى بلادكم عبر
الحدود هؤلاء
الاطفال والنساء وما تركوهم وراءهم من
ازواج
والاباء وامهات
هذا اثبت دعمكم
للاوكرانيين ونحن نؤكد مجددا
وقوفنا تجاه امني اوروبا ونعمل على ضمان
ايضا
القياده
مقر قياده قواتنا في اوروبا سيكون موجودا
في بولندا كما اننا نطلق شراكه استراتيجيه
جديده مع خطط لبناء محطات الطاقه
لتعزيز امن الطاقه في بولندا لاجيال قادمه
السيد الرئيس
هناك رابط قويه بين الشعبين
البولندي والامريكي مزحته مع الرئيس وقلت
له عندما كنت شابا
كنت في
بنسلفانيا
في ضحيه يسكنها الايرلنديون وكان هناك
منطقه اسمها كلارموند في ولايه كان من
يسكنها من الطبقه العامله
وكنت على علم بمدى تاثير
الذهنيه البولنديه على هذه المنطقه
وقلت
للرئيس
مدى الفخر الذي
يشعر به
الامريكيون من اصول بولنديه
السيد الرئيس لو رايتم ذلك وينبغي ان تاتي
لتشاهد ذلك
بعينك انا اواثق انه مهما كانت التحديات
يمكن ان نواجهها معا بفضل شركتنا التي
تسمح لنا بالتصدر التحديات انا واثق لذلك
انا سعيد جدا
لعوده الى وارسو
وطبعا سنجري مناقشات بالتاكيد لن تحل كل
المشكلات ولكن بالتاكيد هذه علاقه مهمه
وحاسمه للولايات المتحده واشكركم جزيل
الشكر على تعاونكم ومساعدتكم